in March 1936 Dorothea Lange was driving
through Nipomo California on her way
home after a long day of work for the
resettlement administration a New Deal
agency created by FDR to relocate
struggling families onto land developed
by the government Lange was a
photographer for the last 15 years or so
she made her living taking portraits of
the San Francisco delete' but after the
Great Depression hit she left her studio
and began to document the effects of the
crisis on residents of the city on
seeing those photographs Roy Stryker
immediately hired her to work for the
government on a project that would
involve documenting poor rural workers
in a propaganda effort to elicit
political support for government aid
Lange was riding home having finished
her work film ready to be sent back to
Washington when she passed a fee Pickers
camp pea picker was a name given to poor
migrants from Eastern cities and towns
who moved West often to California
looking for farm work during the
Depression at this camp
an early morning frost had killed the
crops so some 3,000 people were left in
their makeshift homes with no work some
starving but lying passed them by
exhausted from the day's work it was 20
more miles before she turned around she
didn't stay at the camp long in about
ten minutes she would be back on the
road again but not before taking one of
the most iconic pictures in the history
of photography here's how it happened
on arriving at the camp Lange is
immediately drawn as if by a magnet she
said to a family huddled under a tent
this is likely a test shot there are a
lot of things that make this composition
unpersuasive only the child in the
middle for example is offering her face
to the camera the oldest daughter on the
chair doesn't seem to notice the camera
at all and the mother turns away clearly
defensive not wanting her picture taken
so Lange talks to them as she's learned
to do after working this beat for a long
time and she helps the family arrange
themselves this composition is
definitely more pleasing than the last
but something's still not quite right
and it has to do with the eldest
daughter
year remember these photos have a
purpose to evoke sympathy from voters
that would translate into political
support as James Curtis points out
having an older daughter as well as
three younger ones could suggest to some
that this woman wasn't taking the right
precautions and family planning and was
less deserving of support or in other
words less like them so lang cuts her
off she captures or stages a breast
feeding scene playing on the religious
symbolism of the nursing Madonna but the
picture may have been too extreme for
viewers of that time what's more it was
clearly making the mother uncomfortable
and Lang is starting to realize that she
is the key to the scene specifically her
face so she alters the ankle asks one of
the children to come back in and you can
see the woman easing up but the older
child looks a bit awkward and the post
is blocking part of the baby's head so
lang tries again this time having the
great idea to include the trunk at an
angle and the foreground with the empty
peyten compelling imagery of the
family's struggle and nomadic lifestyle
the child looks wistful the baby is
sleeping and the mother has the right
expression - this is an extraordinary
photograph you can see Lange coming to
it through a series of adjustments it
achieves the objectives of her project
while being aesthetically powerful
it's exactly what Ron striker would have
loved to see but Lange thought she could
do one better this is the photograph you
probably know I don't think you can
really appreciate it until you
understand the ten minutes that came
before a lesser photographer would have
milked the children's faces for their
sympathetic potential Lange even tried
to do that herself but by the time she
arrives here she knows exactly what the
focus needs to be the daughters faces
turn behind their mothers shoulders
communicates that message of family a
family of the right sized mind you
without taking away from the central
face or the eyes which seemed at last to
let down their guard as they search the
distance and worry the face is so
important that Lange has the woman put
her hand on her chin so that her arm
points to it it's a technique that she's
used before anything that took attention
away from the face would hurt the
power of the image which also explains
why Lang had a darkroom assistant
removed the woman's other thumb here
where she was holding the post so that
she could keep her other hand to her
chin all this manipulation of course
speaks to the fact that there is very
little spontaneous in this iconic image
of so-called documentary photography
it's supposed to communicate a candid
truth about the moment but this is
anything but candid whether that
diminishes its power is up to you for me
being able to actually see the steps of
Lang's craft enhances her work it gives
the photograph a third dimension almost
as soon as it was developed this photo
took on a life of its own after it was
published in a San Francisco newspaper
the government sent 20,000 pounds of
food to the migrant camp at Nipomo
stryker
fell in love with it and sent it all
across the country after which it came
to define the depression in the American
consciousness and on a deeper level
it became the archetypal image of
struggling families in any era a second
thought a skilled photographer a mother
her kids and ten minutes in 1936 that
will live forever next time you have an
instinct to turn around listen to it hey
everybody welcome to 2019 thank you so
much for watching this episode was
brought to you by Nord VPN if you care
like I do about your privacy and
security online you should absolutely be
using a VPN or virtual private network
to keep your data safe by allowing you
to connect to stuff remotely so prying
eyes can't see your IP address and
private information I've had a few
hacking scares myself so VPNs really
helped ease my mind and Nord VPN is your
best option if you're watching this
right now you get 75% off a three-year
plan if you go to North Vee p.m. comm
slash nerdwriter plus an extra month
free when the code nerdwriter is used at
the checkout I've shopped around in this
space used a few VPNs and Nord VPN is
definitely my favorite not only does it
have military-grade encryption and over
5,000 servers in 62 countries you can
run it simultaneously on up to six
devices which means you can run it on
computers and your phone so when you're
accessing the Wi-Fi to cafe
or an airport you know you'll be safe
this one's a no-brainer and again nor
VPN is offering my viewers 75% off a
three year plan plus an extra free month
if you use the code nerdwriter at
checkout just go to Nord VPN comm slash
nerdwriter
thanks guys I'll see you next time